for 16 years richard branson has been
promising
a bright future for space tourism and
suborbital space flight but for the past
couple of years
spacex has overshadowed their valiant
efforts in providing reliable space
travel
at the same time though it doesn't seem
like virgin galactic has made any major
breakthroughs either
as they have basically been non-existent
on the news
so what happened to virgin galactic
well starting off virgin galactic has
chosen to take a different path from the
competition
instead of launching passengers in
regular old rocket ships
they have chosen to launch passengers in
private jet like vehicles called
the spaceship 2. the spaceship 2 is
capable of carrying up to 6 passengers
and the 2 pilots into the upper limits
of earth's atmosphere
but it does require a carrier aircraft
the carrier aircraft is called white
knight 2
and will carry spaceship to up to 50 000
ft
at this point spaceship 2 will
disconnect from white knight to
and fire up its own engine which will
propel the vehicle
up to three times the speed of sound or
about 2
300 miles per hour this lasts for about
90 seconds
pushing the vehicle up to 110 kilometers
in altitude
which is exactly the international
boundary in space
once there the passengers will have
about four to five minutes to soak up
the views
and experience weightlessness before the
spacecraft re-enters the earth's
atmosphere
unlike regular re-entries however
spaceship 2 doesn't require
any bulky heat shields that protect the
vehicle as
spaceship 2 doesn't go very far into
space
and it's not traveling tens of thousand
miles per hour either
anyways during the reentry phase the
pilots don't have to do much work
as the spaceship will automatically
complete the required procedures
this is true until the spaceship falls
back to an altitude of 60 to 70 thousand
feet
at this point all that's left is
basically a routine plane landing
as you can see this is in stark contrast
to classic rocket ships that launch
straight upwards
but that's not necessarily a bad thing
first of all
by designing the spaceship 2 as
essentially a plane that can reach high
altitudes virgin galactic
is able to significantly reduce the g's
that passengers will experience
during the trip aside from this the jet
lag approach
also makes reusability a lot easier
those spacex has received a lot of
praise for
quick turnaround times with their falcon
9 rockets spaceship 2
is capable of 1-upping falcon 9 in terms
of turnaround time
in fact the predecessor of the spaceship
2 the spaceship 1
was able to fly into space twice within
two weeks way back in 2004
it should be noted of course that
reusing an orbital booster
is much more difficult than reusing the
spaceship too
but with that being said the fastest
turnaround spacex has achieved
is 51 days moving on the spaceship 2
also provides a much more cost effective
solution when it comes to reaching space
the spaceship too does not make sense if
you're trying to send large payloads
into space but if you're just trying to
get a glimpse of space
within your lifetime virgin galactic is
the cheapest option
currently they're not taking ticket
orders but
in the past they priced their
spaceflight tickets between 200 thousand
and two hundred fifty thousand dollars
there may be a price increase in the
future
but it's expected to stay within the few
hundred thousand dollar range
blue origin is also targeting this price
range for space tourism
around 2024. and we don't have any
pricing information
for space tourism from spacex but
it's likely that spacex's approach to
space tourism
will be much more expensive however it
will also last much longer
for instance the deer moon project from
spacex
is expected to take seven to nine
passengers on a trip
around the moon and accordingly the
price is quite steep
expect it to be about 200 million
dollars or about 25 million dollars per
seat
at the same time though the trip doesn't
last hours or days
but nearly a full week at six to seven
days
even calling it six days this comes out
to a price of about 2
900 per passenger per minute
meanwhile the virgin galactic option is
closer to 50 to 60 k
per minute despite the spacex option
providing a much greater value
proposition
you still have to push out 25 million
dollars per seat
which significantly increases the bar
for entry with the virgin galactic
multi-millionaires can likely afford to
participate
while with spacex passengers likely need
to be worth hundreds of millions of
dollars
before even considering purchasing a
ticket that's
all great and all but when can we
actually expect virgin galactic
to start taking people on these space
flights well
originally richard branson was actually
targeting 2007
as the euro diversion galactic will
place regular people into space
unfortunately however a fatal explosion
that ended up killing three people
would occur in 2007 putting a large dent
into the timeline over the next three
years
virgin galactic would really focus on
improving their design and safety
measures
and they would embark on a crew test
flight in july of 2010.
this was their first successful crew
test flight and lasted a full six hours
after this test flight version galactic
would focus on fundraising
by selling tickets to space and
providing nasa with research flight data
progress would start speeding up once
again in 2013
and 2014 as virgin galactic would
conduct their first
rocket power test flights however they
would soon run into another major
roadblock
in late 2014 during another rocket power
test flight of the space ship
ii which would kill the co-pilot and
leave the pilot injured
after this crash richard branson
actually seriously considered
stopping development as virgin galactic
was not only burning through hundreds of
millions of dollars
but more importantly claiming lives
despite these doubts richard branson and
the team
would push forward and they completed
their first successful reentry test
in since 2017
things have actually been looking pretty
bright for virgin galactic
late last year virgin galactic would
even go public with the stock offering
upon release virgin galactic would rally
up to 37
per share due to the pandemic though
they would crash
all the way back to ten dollars per
share before working back up to twenty
five dollars per share today
anyways until just a few months ago the
plan was to start getting passengers
up to space using the spaceship too by
the end of this year
but recently this was postponed to 2021
this is likely just to ensure the best
possible circumstances before risking
any more lives
so nothing to worry about right now
fortunately
the prospects of commercial space flight
from virgin galactic in the near future
are still quite promising spaceship 2
has
already conducted successful flights
with the crew on board
and they only have two more test flights
to complete before opening up to the
public
the first of these two tests was
originally planned to take place
starting october 22nd but since then
virgin galactic has moved back the test
window to november 19th to november 23rd
at the time of this recording they have
yet to conduct this test
however they may have very well
successfully finished up this test
by the time you guys are watching this
video
but even if they haven't it's just a
matter of time
until they conduct these final two tests
and assuming these tests go well
the only step left is for richard
branson to take an inauguration type
flight
in the spaceship too so it's likely that
we will see virgin galactic's first
commercial space flight take place
by the end of next year but what about
after this
what are virgin galactic's long-term
goals
well virgin galactic will of course
continue to provide
and scale up commercial space flight but
their long-term vision
lies within the mach 3 aircraft which is
basically the concord
2.0 virgin galactic has already received
approval from the faa
to start designing and manufacturing the
mach 3 aircraft
currently the plan is for the mach 3
aircraft to carry anywhere between 9
and 19 people 60 000 feet above sea
level
at three times the speed of sound all
the seats are expected to be either
business
or first class seats coming in at over
one hundred thousand dollars per seat
this is significantly more expensive
than spacex's plan for point-to-point
travel
using their starship rocket which is
expected to come in at several grand
but virgin galactic's plan does sound a
lot more feasible
as a similar plan has already been
enacted decades ago with the concorde
at the same time though we all know how
the concord turned out
so persian galactic will really have to
prove safety
and reliability before people start
trusting the mach 3.
if they are able to pull it off however
we will be seeing flights between new
york
and london taking just two and a half
hours and
flights between tokyo and a lake just
taking 3 or 4 hours
after developing a reliable concorde
virgin galactic
may target putting people back on the
moon themselves or helping blue origin
and nasa put humans back on the moon
richard branson
has previously revealed that he favors
returning to the moon first
before embarking on a mars mission so
it's likely that virgin galactic will
set their eyes on the moon as well
before mars at the end of the day vs
galactic
is getting awfully close to making
commercial space flight a reality
by the end of next year after
accomplishing this
it seems like they're planning on
providing rapid point-to-point travel
using supersonic jets finally persian
galactic may focus on helping humans
get back to the moon and that's what's
happening with the virgin galactic
do you guys think virgin galactic can
become a strong competitor in the space
flight market
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited to see richard
branson
become the first billionaire to travel
into space and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one